l'arctique cette région du monde revêt
un intérêt stratégique pour bien des
nations et pourrait être en lire
certains journaux au centre d'un futur
conflit global afin de s'y préparer
l'otan organise tous les deux ans des
manoeuvres militaires dans le nord de la
norvège dans des conditions
particulièrement hostile aux menons ces
exercices réalisme dans un environnement
extrêmement difficile
les forces américaines qui prennent part
aux côtés des forces norvégiennes
d'allier et de partenaires affineront
leurs compétences létale leur
intéropérabilité entretiendront des
relations de travail clés et
s'acclimateront aux défis posés en
combattant dans un froid extrême et sur
un terrain accidenté l'environnement
changeant et la concurrence stratégique
accrue dans la région arctique vont
créer des menaces mais nos forces seront
prêtes à y répondre partout où elle se
pose pendant près d'un mois de 15 à 16
milles soldats issus de 9 pays vont
participer à plusieurs exercices des
manoeuvres au sein desquels la russie
n'a clairement pas le bon rôle selon le
scénario de cet exercice militaire après
avoir débarqué et collecté chars et
autres armes lourdes
la colonne se dirigera vers l'extrême
nord du pays pour aider les forces
norvégiennes a repoussé les forces
russes supposé avoir traversé la
frontière les deux parties s'engageront
alors je cite dans des opérations de
combat de haute intensité dans des
conditions arctiques des exercices comme
cold respawns 2020 montre les capacités
la coopération la force et l'engagement
inébranlable ainsi que la détermination
et le dévouement des états unis et de
leurs alliés et partenaires à maintenir
sécurité et stabilité dans l'arctique et
la russie dans tout ça moscou a
clairement désigné la région arctique
comme un axe de développement majeur à
court et moyen termes de développement
économique d'abord avec le potentiel
énorme que représente la route maritime
du nord même si la russie renforce ses
infrastructures militaires sur place
c'est selon elle pour accompagner ce
développement et assurer la sécurité de
cette zone stratégique
nous sommes convaincus qu'il n'ya pas de
conflits potentiels dans l'arctique et
que toutes les questions qui se posent
peuvent et doivent être résolus par les
moyens politiques à la table des
négociations
aucun de ces problèmes de nécessite une
issue militaire afin de renforcer la
confiance la compréhension mutuelle
et de prévenir toute escalade nous
soutenons l'établissement d'un dialogue
militaro politique à grande échelle
entre les états de l'arctique
klitschko showdown mais voilà l'otan et
washington plus particulièrement
raffolent de ces exercices ou la soi
disant menace russe est prise très au
sérieux
toujours dans l'arctique il ya déjà eu
les exercices nordine edge en alaska en
sans oublier defender europe 2020 qui se
déroulera ce printemps et qui est appelé
à représenter les plus grandes
manoeuvres menées par les états unis sur
le vieux continent depuis 25 ans autant
d'exercices et de simulation de guerre
face à la russie qui ne viennent pas
franchement apaiser les tensions avec
moscou